my daughter thinks I'm a mechanic she
asked me what I do for a living and I
tell her I work on cars I've always
thought about honoring my dad and just
because it's such a big part of his life
and
of course I actually had to take her on
set with me for Fast and the Furious and
she goes Daddy what are you doing I'm
like I just I'm just fixing the car and
we're out the door and I wanted it to be
something super small and simple that
was almost like if you didn't know
no she has no clue it's just a matter of
time until she puts it together but I
try to keep it as real as possible tell
my dad would want me like my dad was
very humble very simple so I thought
like the best way to sister would have
this like very special moment that was
quite sure but like left my little Mark
and I can always share that with him